Kaley Cuoco gives fans a glimpse of her
growing baby bump I just love it the
flight attendant star share this sweet
snap showing off her maternity style in
a blue floral dress alongside her boo
Tom Pelfrey the Ozark star cradling her
belly as they smile for the camera
Kaylee writes over the pick m and d a
nod to their new roles as Mom and Dad
and I'm so excited the parents to be
enjoyed a lot of family time over the
Thanksgiving holiday sharing this photo
Rocking New York Giants jerseys and
check out the couple holding up a mini
version Kaylee's caption future
footballer coming at ya it makes me so
happy Tom and Kaylee announced in
October they're expecting their first
child a baby girl Kaylee shared a series
of pics at the time and gushed baby girl
palfrey come in 2023 Beyond blessed and
over the moon I love you Tom Pelfrey it
was love at first sight but Kaylee's not
the only one celebrating her former Big
Bang Theory showrunner Chuck Laurie
recently opened up to T about the
exciting baby news just genuinely a
big-hearted warm and wonderful and
Incredibly skilled actress and
congratulations having a baby
they are just so happy I'm so thrilled
for her and they're going to be such
great parents I I absolutely know it so
so thrilled and Chuck he has an idea of
what kind of Mama Kaylee is going to be
she's gonna be a helicopter mom
you're all over this kid for as busy as
Kaylee is she is so on top of things she
will be she will have a chart for this
kid I mean it will be amazing
foreign